a pair of global summits the first in
rome where leaders of the world's
wealthiest nations will discuss the
pandemic climate change and rising
energy costs the g20 summit will be
their first face-to-face meeting in two
years and expectations are high
delegates will then converge on glasgow
in scotland for two weeks of make or
break climate talks the meeting has been
described as the last best chance to get
climate change under control after
touching down in rome for the g20 u.s
president joe biden took the opportunity
to visit pope francis at the vatican
biden is a devout catholic and only the
second catholic president after john f
kennedy
following his meeting with the pontiff
biden headed to talks with french
president emmanuel macron he was keen to
repair relations with france after the
u.s and the united kingdom agreed to
provide australia with nuclear-powered
submarines
one day before g20 leaders begin their
deliberations un secretary general
antonio guterres warned the club of
richest nations that they must do more
to help poorer countries
and he issued a stark warning that all
sides must come together to achieve a
common cause
we see dangerous levels of mistrust
among the big powers
among members of the g20
between developed and developing
countries including emerging economies
and so the most important objective of
this g20 summit must be to re-establish
trust
by tackling the main sources of mistrust
rooted in injustices inequalities and
geopolitical divides
we have team coverage tonight on the day
i'm joined now by our brussels bureau
chief alexander von naaman in rome and
our washington bureau chief inez poll in
washington dc welcome to you both
alexandra to you first pope francis and
president biden met up arguably the
world's two most famous catholics
inside knowledge on whether the two hit
it off and what was on their agenda
so they prayed they prayed for peace and
us president biden said that they also
talked about their climate emergency and
the moral responsibility to have to deal
with the issue
and apparently pope francis was very
focused on the impact of climate change
on disadvantaged communities according
to the white house they also talk about
the coronavirus pandemic and
pope francis urged joe biden to do more
to provide vaccines to poorer nations
and apparently joe biden said that they
are moving
heaven and earth to deliver those
vaccines to poorer nations and overall
we have to say that the us president
seemed to be very impressed by this
meeting he described it as wonderful
they spent 90 minutes together
in vatican
75 of it
in private
you know as the elephant in the room at
the pontiff president audience may very
well have been abortion rights
biden contentiously supports them amid a
fierce debate state side
yeah it might be hard to believe for our
international audience but abortion has
become indeed a leading issue here in
the united states in the political
debate and president biden never
left any doubt from the very beginning
on of his presidency and even before
when he was campaigning that he's
absolutely
supporting
pro-choice and that a woman should have
the final say if she wants an abortion
or not but
also michael just hours ago
as alexandra just pointed out during
this obviously very warm
and happy meeting the pope announced
that he believes that president biden is
i quote a good catholic and that he
should continue to receive communion and
that means something because there were
many objections to that from
conservative catholics all around the
world and also bishops here in the
united states
i would say that's a bit of breaking
news therein as uh alexandria biden also
met his french counterpart emmanuel
macron
u.s french ties have been strained
recently over the alkas defense pact
did they take meaningful steps to mend
relations
well i think yes and my impression was
that they were really determined to show
that their friends again and that they
want to look ahead and not back however
us president biden acknowledged that the
way his administration
handled or let's say communicated the
ocus partnership
was not very clever clumsy as he put it
and he praised france as a very
important partner saying that there is
no
decent no more loyal and decent u.s ally
both leaders agreed on a closer
cooperation in the future in many areas
you as president biden promised to
provide more support for the french
mission in the sahel region and he also
stressed the importance of the french
role in the indo-pacific region and the
role the european union is playing there
so i would say that this meeting was
good for
us president joe biden but it was really
a success for french president macron
alexander let's stay with you just for a
moment that the g20 summit
kicks off in earnest on saturday ahead
of the cop 26 climate summit in scotland
of course what do world leaders need to
achieve in rome to lay the groundwork
for glasgow
well they need to show that they are
ready to take bold climate action that
they are ready to have more ambitious
climate goals that they are ready to
agree on a date to phase out coal for
example that they are ready to make good
on their promise to provide 100 billion
us dollars a year to help poorer nations
combat climate change and its
consequences however we have to say when
we look what's
happening we have no reason to be very
optimistic for example joe biden's
climate plan is stalled in congress
china has already said that they are
rejected
rejecting calls for more ambitious
climate goals so as you can see there is
really at the moment at least no reason
to be very optimistic here back to you
and as uh before biden left for rome he
announced plans uh for the biggest
investment in climate action in u.s
history now we understand there's some
sort of setback
right just as alexandra pointed out i
mean the president was hoping
to head to glasgow with the political
momentum of having past and scientists
his environmental spending deal
and he was hoping to show the
international community what he was able
to achieve
here at home but instead he indeed comes
empty-handed
as he didn't get his plans through and
that will definitely not strengthen his
negotiation positions
and it will not put him into the
position where he wanted to be in the
seat of the world leader for climate
change last question for you nasa the us
and china are the world's
two top carbon admitters yet biden and
chinese president xi jinping have not
met face to face and u.s china relations
are at a low end
is that poisoning efforts to achieve
international consensus on climate
um very good question michael i mean
advisors to the president have said that
the absence of china won't be an
obstacle as they work to get a formal
agreement on climate change policies and
that biden and the rest of the west are
hoping
that the negotiations will showcase that
the leading democracies are capable
of working together to solve current and
future threats to climate but
still it is a symbolic signal from china
by not sitting at the table and it will
make not only the talks much more
difficult
but weaken any possible outcome i think
even before the summit has started let's
see what comes out of this that's inez
poll in washington d.c of course and
alexandra van naman in rome really
appreciate your time